[موسيقى]
يستعد المراقبون العرب في سوريا لزياره
حما وادلب ودرعا بعد زيارتهم حمص وعنها
قال رئيس الوفد ان الوضع في المدينه جيد
لكنه يحتاج لمزيد من التحقق غير ان وكالات
الانباء نقلت عن سكان في باب عمرو خيبه
املهم من مستوى تجاوب المراقبين مع شكواهم
وسور الشكوك ايضا ساورت الشكوك عددا من
المعارضه السوريه في الخارج بشان فاعليه
عمل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الفريق حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في عنوانين رئيسيين بعد زياره حمص
ما هي اسباب حاله الشك التي تساور اطرافا
سوريه ودوليه تجاه عمل المراقبين
هل سيختلف اسلوب عمل المراقبين العرب خلال
زيارات المناطق الاخرى عما جرى في
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حمص بينما يراقب المراقبون العرب الاوضاع
في المدن السوريه يراقب عملهم السوريون
والعرب والعالم ورغم ان الاصل في مهمتهم
هي وضع اجابات للاسئله المطروحه بشان
الوضع في سوريا الى ان زياره حمص وتصريحات
رئيس الوفد بعدها طرحت اسئله اكثر عن
اسلوب عملهم الرقابي تحت رقابه الامن
السوري المتهم باستهداف من يدلون
بشهاداتهم للمراقبين
العرب المراقبين الع ليسوا كثيرين اولئك
الذين يتجرؤون على الحديث الى مراقبي
الجامعه العربيه في سوريا فمثل هذا الحديث
سيكون له ثمنه ان لم ياتي كما يشتهي
النظام ذلك ان المرا قب العربي الذي يبدو
هنا زائغ النظرات وهو يستمع الى شكاوى
المواطنين في غير م اكتراث يرافقه في
الغالب واحد او اكثر من عناصر النظام
الذين يستمعون الى ما يقوله المواطنون
بمنتهى الانتباه والحرص وهو امر يجعل من
وفد المراقبين ما يشبه الفخاخ المعده
للايقاع
بالمعارضين قبل وصوله الى هذا المنزل في
حمص كان هذا المراقب وبقيه زملائه في
ضيافه محافظ حمص الذي اختاروا ان يستمعوا
الى روايته اولا قبل الانطلاق لمقابله
المواطنين بدايه دعمت راي من يرون انه ليس
من الحكمه التعويل على شهادات يلقى بها
على عجل في اسماع مراقبين يحرسهم ذات
السلاح الذي كان سببا في شكاوى الشاكين
وتوجه تصرفاتهم ذات التصورات المحذره من
عصابات مسلحه يقول المعارضون انها لا توجد
الا في روايات النظام بيد ان هذا ليس
الماخذ الوحيد للمعارضين على بعثه
المراقبه العربيه فبعد يومين من نزول
عناصرها الى الارض يتحدث معارضون عن ترحيل
النظام معتقلين واخفاء اسلحه ثقيله من
الاماكن التي زارها المراقبون وهو امر ترى
المعارضه انه كان واضحا منذ البدايه ومن
دون الذهاب مع النظام في لعبه كسب الوقت
لمواصله قمع المتظاهرين الذين سقط منهم
العشرات خلال اليومين الاولين لعمل بعثه
المراقبه ذلك انه لم يكن من الم صور اصلا
من وجهه نظر المعارضين ان يحتفظ النظام
بمعتقل داخل السجون او باسلحتهم الثقيله
داخل المدن والبلدات التي يفترض ان وصول
المراقبين اليها لن يتم الا بالتنسيق
المسبق معه ابعد من ذلك يقول المشككون ان
المراقبين العرب يتعامون عمدا عن الحقيقه
حين لا يقرون بان نظام الاسد لم يلتزم
مثلا بالسماح لاجهزه الاعلام الاجنبيه
بالدخول والعمل بحريه رغم ان هذا من صميم
مما ادعى الالتزام به ورغم ان صور هؤلاء
المراقبين انفسهم لا تصل الى العالم الا
عبر كاميرات الهواتف الجواله وغيرها من
الوسائط المختلسه من وراء ظهر
النظام لمناقشه هذه القضيه ينضم الينا من
القاهره الدكتور وليد البني عضو الامانه
العامه ومدير مكتب العلاقات الخارجيه في
المجلس الوطني السوري من القاهره ايضا
محمود شكري المحلل السياسي وسفير مصر
السابق لدى سوريا من عمان معنا الدكتور
لؤي ديب رئيس الشبكه الدوليه للحقوق
والتنميه وابدا معك سيد وليد
البني الاليه التي بدات بها زياره الوفد
اليوم والتصريحات التي ادلى بها رئيس
الوفد هل تستحق كل هذا التشكيك الذي
نسمعه في الحقيقه انا كنت قد التقيت رئيس
الوفد قبل ان يغادر القاهره قد تكلمنا
بصراحه وقد قال لي من اولى مهامه وقبل ان
يبدا هو ان يتم سحب الجيش والاليات من
الشارع وان يتوقف اطلاق النار على
المتظاهرين ما استغربه حقيقه انه بعد
يومين من وجودهم داخل سوريا لا يزال القتل
مستمرا ولا تزال الاليات موجوده ولا يزال
الجيش يحتل الشوارع ويقتل المتظاهرين
ويطلق النار عليهم هذه النقيصه الاولى
التي ناخذها على عمل لجنه المراقبه اربع
مهام اساسيه شرحها هو
لي عندما التقيت به اولها ان يتوقف القتل
ويسحب الجيش وتسحب الاليات من الشارع
ثانيها ان يسمح للاعلام بان يتواجد بحريه
وان ينقل الحقيقه الى الاخ الى الى الى
جميع انحاء العالم وليس فقط كاميرات
الجوال وكانه ليس هناك بروتوكولا عربيا
ليس هناك مبادره عربيه وكانه ليس هناك
لجنه مراقبه موجوده على الاراضي السوريه
ثالث هذه الشروط هي اطلاق جميع المعتقلين
السياسيين الذين يزيد ع عددهم عن 30,000
لا يزالون موجودون بل ولا يزال الاعتقال
مستمرا ولا يزال التعذيب مستمرا
ايه في الحقيقه شرطا واحد من هذه الشروط
لم ينفذ ونسمع مع كل اسف اذا كان صحيحا
بانه يقول بان الوضع مرضي لا ادري ما هو
المرضي وانا لم استمع اليه مباشره يتكلم
سمعتها بوسائل الاعلام بان الوضع في حمص
جيد ما هو الجيد في حمص اليوم هناك جرحى
وقتلى البارحه قتل اكثر من 10 اشخاص في
حمص اليوم لدينا 19 قتيلا في سوريا لا
اعتقد انه ج جادا عندما يقول بان الوضع
جيد ولا اعتقد ان بهذه الطريقه سوف نتمكن
من تطبيق المبادره العربيه التي بنينا
عليها امالا كبيره بانها سوف تساعدنا في
ايقاف القتل والتعذيب الذي يمارسه النظام
ضد شعبنا منذ اكثر من 10 اه سيد محمود
شكري عندما يقول رئيس الوفد يعني بعد
زياره لم تستمر وجوله لم تستمر اكثر من
ساعتين في حمص يقول ان الوضع يعني هناك في
بعض الاماكن غير جيد ولكنه ليس مثيرا
للخوف هل ترى في ذلك شيء من
استعجال
انا يعني دعيني اكون او احاول ان اكون
محايدا في هذا الموقف بالذات اولا رئيس
هذه البعثه ا هو شخصيه سودانيه
ومحمد احمد مصطفى الدابي يعني ليس محسوبا
على سوريا في شيء وانما هو معين من قبل
جمعه الدول العربيه وان
رئيس هذه الجامعه في هذا الوقت بالذات هي
قطر ونحن نعلم مواقف قطر وحرصها الشديد
على ان تقوم جامعه الدول العربيه بالدور
المنوط بها وان اختيار هذا الشخص بالذات
ليس محسوبا على احد ومن ثم فنحن نرى ان
ا الوقت الذي قضته هذه البعثه لا يسمع لا
يسمح بتوجيه النقد الحاد اليها كما ولا
يسمح في ذات الوقت في التشكيك بعملها
وانما المفروض ان تعطى هذه اللجنه الوقت
الكافي لكي يمكنها ان تتبين الموقف هي كما
قال الزميل من قبلي هي لديها فقط ساعتين
تحاسب عليهما ولا اعتقد ان مثل هذا القول
ينفي ان ان تكون
هذه اللجنه تقوم بعملها هذا مجرد بدايه
طيب لؤي ديب يعني في النهايه يعني هذا
الرجل رئيس اللجنه موجود في سوريا ربما من
الطبيعي انه لا يريد ان يستعدي الجهات
المسؤوله في هذه المرحله ومن ثم هذا
الكلام فقط لمتهم وربما بعد ان تنتهي
المهمه سنسمع قولا
اخر
دعيني دعيني اناقش الامر من جانب اخر يعني
انا سانق الامر من جانب مهني كانسان حقوقي
مختص اولا هذه البعثه تم تشكيلها على عجل
دون معايير دون ضوابط لعملها دون دون وجود
قانون لانتقاء هؤلاء الاشخاص انا لا لا
اتهجم على هؤلاء الاشخاص ولكن هذه البعثه
كان يجب ان يكون هناك معايير لانتقاء
الاشخاص الذين
فيها هذه النقطه يعني في النهايه هي ايضا
سابقه للجامعه العربيه ليست هناك تجربه
سابقه تستند اليها وتتعلم منها
صحيح صحيح ولكن ولكن هناك موافقه سوريه
مشروطه مسبقه على اسماء المراقبين هذا
الامر ادى الى انسحاب عشرات المراقبين
وعدم قبولهم بالمهمه وادى الى ان الذين
دخلوا دخلوا بامر سوري وهناك اناس ابعدوا
بامر سوري هذا شيء اخر البعثه عددها وصل
الى 150 شخص لا تستطيع تغطيه المساحه
الجغرافيه لسوريا تم تقزيم عملها هذه
البحثه لا تحتوي على خبراء في الطب الشرعي
لا تحتوي على خبراء في الطب النفسي لا
تحتوي على خبراء في صدمه الاطفال هذه بعثه
لا تمتلك اي ا لا تمتلك اي اجهزه او معدات
لفحص القنابل لفحص الادوات يعني هذه
البعثه فقيره جدا اذا كانت الجامعه
العربيه لا تمتلك لا تمتلك الخبرات فان
المجتمع المدني العربي الذي تم تغييبه
قصدا ويعني تم الاشاره للمجتمع العربي بال
المدني بمنظمه او منظمتين لنقول ان
المجتمع العربي المدني قد مشاركه في هذه
البعثه لا يا سيدتي هناك الكثير من
الخبراء العرب تم استثنائهم كان هناك
اتفاق مع جامعه الدول العربيه تم تزويد
جامعه الدول العربيه بعشرات الاسماء لم
يذهب في هذه البعثه الا موظفون حكوميين
ممن رشحتهم الدول وممن وافقت عليهم
السلطات السوريه اذا نحن امام بعثه فقيره
لا تمتلك امكانيات لا تمتلك الخبرات طبيعي
سينتج عن هذه البعثه تخبط بعثه لا تمتلك
يعني حتى الادوات لا تمتلك لا تمتلك
كاميرات متخصصه مرتبطه بالجي بي اس مرتبطه
بالاقمار الصناعيه لتحديد المكان لتحديد
لتحديد الحاله هم يصورون بموبايلات
الشخصيه نحن انا اخشى اننا امام حاله
سيكون فيها الضحايا السوريين كما كان
الحال في رواندا والكونجو والبوسنه
والهرسك ثم سنفي ق على كارثه مفجعه امام
يعني امام التخبط والاجراءات وعدم الخبره
هذا كلام لا يجوز في عام 2011 ونحن قد
تحطنا الى السفير محمود شكري يعني انت
اثرت نقطه وقلت ان الوفد او اللجنه يراسها
شخص غير محسوب على اي جهه هو الفريق او
الركن محمد احمد مصطفى الدابي ولكن اريد
ان اطرح عليك سؤال في الواقع طرحه ايريك
ريفز الاستاذ في كليه سميث كولج في
الولايات المتحده قال لماذا تختار الجامعه
العربيه شخصا لقياده اللجنه ينتمي لجيش
مودان بنفس نوعيه الجرائم التي يجري
التحقيق فيها في سوريا هذا سؤال
مشروع والله انا نفسي انا نفسي لا استطيع
ان اجيب على هذ هذا السؤال
لان يعني انا كان المفترض ان الذي يوافق
على هذه اللجنه كان مجلس وزراء العرب او
المجلس الوزاري العربي وانما ما ما وافق
على هذه اللجنه هي اللجنه المنوط بها من
مجلس
الجامعه لحل الواقع في الارض السوريه
ثانيا نحن نعلم ان الواقع في الارض
السوريه ليس وضعا مريحا وانما هو وضع مهتز
ونحن نرى بكل وضوح ان ما يحدث هو مجزره
وان ما يتم من كلا الجانبين هي معركه لا
نهايه لها ف كان امامنا حاجه من اثنين اما
ان نقبل الوضع كما هو وبامكانياته وليست
بالامكانيات التي يتحدث عنها خبير الذي
سبقني في الحديث لان هذه هذه الامكانيات
تحتاج الى لجنه يعني على مستوى عالي جدا
جدا من الدرايه وان يكون
الوضع في يد شخص يستطيع ان يفرض هذا
الكلام البروتوكول الذي عرض على سوريا
وعارضته تدخل الدكتور علي الغتيت المحامي
الدولي لكي يمكن تيسير الامر ولكي يمكن ان
يحل مشاكل ولكي يمكن ان يوجد صيغه معينه
يبدا بها الحديث لمحاوله رتق الثياب ما
بين المقاومه وما بين او ما بين المعارضه
وما بين الجانب السوري او الحكم السوري
واقع الحال ان سوريا لازال النظام فيها
مسيطرا على الوضع في الداخل ومن ثم هز
هيبه سوريا في هذه المرحله بالذات ليس
بالسهل الموضوع ليس كما كان الوضع بالنسبه
لليبيا كما وانه ليس كما هو الوضع عليه
في في اليمن الوضع في سوريا هي دوله يسيطر
عليها نظام حكم هذا النظام يفرض ارادته لم
يهتز هذا النظام بعد ومن ثم الدخول في هذه
المرحله يلزم ان يكون بشيء من الدقه وبشيء
من الوعي السياسي نعم واضح ربما لهذا سيد
وليد البني يذهب البعض الى الق ان هذا
الاختيار كما حصل ربما لان الجامعه
العربيه يعني لا تريد ان يصل مراقبها
لنتائج ربما تجبرهم على تحرك اقوى من
البقاء في اطار الجامعه
العربيه نحن ليس لدينا شيك بان المجازر
ارتكبت والانتهاكات موجوده وقد قام
المتظاهرون بتصويرها وراينا معا على
الشاشات نحن لا نقول بانهم يجب ان يخترعوا
البارود مره اخرى هناك امور واضحه ولكن
هناك اسس هناك مبادئ اساسيه من من اهم هذه
المبادئ ان لا يذهبوا لكي يراقبوا برفقه
قوى الامن السوريه لان قوى الامن السوريه
سوف ترهب الاخرين من ان يقدموا شهاداتهم
ومن يقترب قد يلقى مصرعه ف ليس من المنطق
ان تقوم هذه اللجنه بزياره حمص او بابا
عمر بمرافقه قوى الامن السوريه وهذا هذا
ليس موجود في البروتوكول اصلا ليس من
المنطق ان يبدا العمل ولا تزال الدبابات
موجوده على الارض ولا يزال القناصون
موجودون على الاسطح ولا يزال النار يطلق
تطلق على المتظاهرين انا عندما تكلمت مع
معالي الامين العام للجامعه العربيه ومع
السيد رئيس اللجنه قالوا بان الهدف او او
او النقطه الاولى من مهمتهم هي ان يتوقف
القتل وان يسحب الجيش من الشوارع وان
يتوقف اطلاق النار بينما نراهم يمارسون
مهامهم ويسقط في نفس اليوم 19 قتيلا اليوم
واكثر من 20 او 25 قتيلا البارحه واللجنه
تمارس مهامها في المراقبه اذا الهدف الاول
من البروتوكول العربي لم يتحقق لم يتوقف
القتل لم يسحب الجيش من الشارع الهدف
الثاني لم يطلق سراح المعتقلين لم يسمح
لوسائل الاعلام بان
تتواجد تنقل ما يجري بحريه وشفافيه اطلق
عدد كبير من المعتقل يطلق صراح 700 ويعتقل
1000 سيدتي طيب اذا اسئله كثيره في الواقع
ومنها ايضا لماذا لا يعتمد عنصر المباغته
لماذا يجب الاعلان بشكل صريح وواضح عن
جدول زياره لجنه المراقبه نطرح هذا السؤال
بعد الفاصل ارجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد الى حلقتنا التي
نناقش فيها جدول اعمال واليه عمل لجنه
المراقبه التي تزور سوريا حاليا اذا سيد
لؤي ديب يعني هذا الاعلان بكل تفصيل عن
المدن التي سيتم زيارتها وتوزيع حتى الفرق
وعدد من سيزور كل فريق هل تعتبر ان هذا
ربما يخدم مهمه
اللجنه يقتل عنصر المباغت
المهم هو لا يخدم هو يدلل على عدم خبره
على عدم درايه هذه تصريحات يعني منذ
البدايه كنا نناقشها اليوم كنت اناقشها مع
العديد من المنظمات الدوليه كيف تع اللجنه
عن اماكن زيارتها وعن اماكن انتشارها نحن
يعني انا استغرب ما هي اليات حمايه الشهود
في هذه اللجنه ما هي الامتيازات والحصانات
التي يتمتع بها اعضاء هذه اللجنه كيف تسمح
هذه اللجنه لنفسها ان تستجوب شهود بحضور
عناصر من الامن السوري هي تعرض الض تعرض
الشهود وتعرض الناس للخطر هناك افتقار قله
الخبره هذه ستجلب مزيد من الضمار قله
الخبره هذه ستجلب ستجلب مزيد من الماسي
انا اتمنى على جمعه الدول العربيه ان كانت
هذه الجامعه او وليس منا من يشك في
مصداقيه جامعه الدول العربيه ان كانت لا
تملك الخبره ان تقول انني لا املك الخبره
ان تستعين بالخبرات لكن ان تؤدي قله
الخبره الى المزيد من الماسي الى المزيد
من الضحايا هذا امر مؤسف جدا هذا الامر قد
سبق وان حدث في العديد من مناطق العالم ان
ادت قله الخبره في عمل اللجان او قله
الخبره في عمل مراقبين دوليين الى حدوث
ماسي ماسي كثيره جدا نحن الان نتحدث عن
لجنه عربيه لا تمتلك خبرات يمكن ان تعرض
عشرات الشهود للخطر هذه اللجنه نفس
اعضائها لا يمتلكون اي امتيازات او حصنات
ثم نحن لا نعرف جامعه الدول العربيه على
موقع على الموقع الالكتروني لم تعلن ما هو
قانون عمل هذه اللجنه هل هذه اللجنه ستكون
بالفعل في النهايه مستقله وتكتب تقريرها
بشكل مستقل دون الرجوع للامين العام دون
الرجوع للدول هذه اللجنه هل هي يعني هل
كان اختيار رجل عس عسكري لرئاسه هذه
اللجنه ليكون فيها نوع من المركزيه هي
بالاصل يفترض ان تكون لجنه مدنيه فيها
خبراء عسكريين ليس ان ياتي رجل عسكري
ليراس لجنه مراقبه مدنيه الامور
كلها فيها ريبه فيها شك فيها تخبط انا
ادعو المراقبين العرب الذين يتواجدون
الارض على الارض السوريه ان كانوا يحسوا
ان عملهم سيجلب خطرا على السكان المدنيين
او ان عملهم لن يحقق نتيجه ان ينسحبوا من
هذه البعثه ان ينسحبوا من هذه البعثه وان
يعطوا فرصه اخرى لحل اخر على الارض
السوريه سفير محمود شكري هل ترى اي احتمال
لمثل هذا الكلام خصوصا ان الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه قبل اسبوع قال
لرويترز ان يتوقع انه خلال اسبوع سيتضح ما
اذا كانت الحكومه بالفعل تتجاوب مع لجنه
المراقبه الان كما ذكر يعني خلال هذه
الحلقه ونشاهده اعمال العنف
والقتل
مستمره
يا استاذه ليلي يعني خلينا نتكلم باسلوب
واقعي يعني نحن نتعامل مع المريض كما هو
ليس كما يجب ان يكون نحن امام ازمه وهذه
الازمه امامنا وان الواقع في سوريا ان
هناك مذابح وان المذابح قائمه وان
المعارضه موجوده وان المعارضه لها اسياف
وان الجيش له اسياف وان الوضع مرتبك في
داخل سوريا وامامنا احد امرين اما اننا
نلجا الى
المنظرين ونترك الوضع كما كما هو عليه
ونقف كعرب نتامل ما يحدث او اننا نبدا
بالخطوه الاولى ثم بعد هذا نرى ماذا سيكون
عليه الموقف لو احلنا هذا الموضوع الى الى
مجلس
الامن فرضا واستصدار
بايفاد لجنه لجنه مراقبه ولم توافق سوريا
على ارسال هذه اللجنه الا بشروط
محدده هل سيمكن ان نوقف حمام الدم الموجود
حاليا ام نسعى الى الخطوه الاولى وهي
محاوله ان نلملم الموقف الحالي ونترك
الخبراء لذاتهم ثم بعد هذا
نحاسبهم انما من الاول كده واحنا قاعدين
نقول ان هم
خبوا راحت فين الدبابات اللي هم بيتكلموا
عليها والقتلى الذين يتحدثون
عنها هم فين يعني لجنه المراقبه مش
شايفاهم طيب خلينا نترك
الفرصه لوليد البني يعني واضح ان هناك من
يشكك في التشكيك يعني
التضليل غير مقنع بالنسبه للبعض ما
تعليقك حقيقه هو يسال اين ذ ذهبت الدبابات
الدبابات لا تزال موجوده في الشارع
الدبابات لا تزال تطلق النار ولكن لم يسمح
لهذه اللجنه ان تذهب وتصور هذه الدبابات
ولا تمتلك هذه اللجنه الادوات الكافيه حتى
تصورها يسال اين هم القتلى ف القتلى
يصورون على شاشات التلفزيون اهالي القتلى
موجودون ويقولون ويدفنون موتاهم وتشيع
الجنازات يعني استغرب جدا مثل هذا الكلام
من سعده السفير انا نفسي كنت هناك وانا
رايت بعيني ماذا يجري ويوميا تنقل وسائل
الاعلام وعبر وعبر تصوير بسيط من قبل
المتظاهرين اناس يقتلون في الشارع وانس
يقام بدفنهم عمليات التعذيب اليوميه التي
شاهدتها انا نفسي عندما كنت في السجن انا
لا ادري هو يسال اين هم القتله اين 10
الاف قتيل حتى الان هل يريد ان نعدد له
اسمائهم هل يريد ان ان نلهم على عناوين
منازلهم حتى تذهب تذهب هذه اللجنه بحريه
وتسال عنهم هل يريد ان ندله على من تعرض
للتعذيب واصيب بالشلل الرباعي وهو موجود
في منزله وبين اهله ونحن زودنا اللجنه بكل
ذلك ما عليها الا ان تذهب الى تلك المنازل
وتسال عن هؤلاء القتلى عن هؤلاء الجرحه عن
هذا الوضع اللا انساني الذي يعاني منه
الشعب السوري لا ادري سعاده السفير هل
يريد هو ان يرى هؤلاء وهل يري هل يت
ستتمكن هذه اللجنه بمرافقه الامن السوري
من تصوير ما يجري على الارض من من قصف
لمنازل من منازل مقصوفه وهي مرافقه من قبل
الامن السوري و وحدد لها الاماكن مسبقا
التي ستذهب خصوص ان هناك
منظمات منظمات حقوقيه السيد لؤي ديب تتحدث
عن نقل معتقلين الى اماكن خارج غير عسكريه
لا يمكن للمراقبين ربما زيارتها وايضا
تغيير اسماء شوارع وما الى ذلك كل هذا
سمعناه ربما هذا ما دفع وحيد عبد المجيد
مركز الاهرام الدراسات كي يقول ان لم يعد
امام الجامعه ان تفعل اي شيء هو قال يخشى
ان
يتحول الفريق او الوفد الى شاهد زور عن
عمد وان يلقى باللوم على
الطرفين انا يعني انا لا اريد ان اتجنى
على هذه اللجنه ولكن انا اتحدث عن وقائع
يعني سعاده السفير للاسف يخلط ما بين
السياسي والقانوني ما بين الملاحقه
الجنائيه والسياسي يا سيدي هناك يمكن ان
يكون هناك مبادرات سياسيه ولكن ليس على
حساب الدم وليس على حساب الملاحقه
الجنائيه وكشف الحقيقه وجبر الضرر وحق
المعرفه للشعب السوري الشعب السوري من حقه
ان يعرف من قتل قتلاه وضحاياه هناك اكثر
من 5000 قتيل قبل وصول اللجنه هل عفى الله
عما سلف ام كان يجب ان تحتوي هذه اللجنه
وتتملك ادوات وتتملك اطباء في الطب الشرعي
يستخرجون الجثت ويحددون هذه جته فلان ابن
فلان قتل بشض او برصاصه يوم كذا وبتاريخ
كذا ودفن هنا بحضور اهله او بدون حضور
اهله هكذا تكون لجان المراقبه هكذا تكون
لجان التحقيق كان هذه اللجنه يجب منذ
وصولها منذ اللحظه الاولى لوصولها ان
ينسحب الجيش السوري ويعود الى داخل
الكونات لتستطيع ممارسه عملها لا ان تمارس
عملها بصحبه الجيش السوري كان على هذه
اللجنه ان تقوم بعملها بشكل حر دون مرافقه
امنيه د د دون تبعات كان يجب ان تمتلك
ادوات لحمايه الشهود هذه اللجنه ان بقيت
ان بقي الامر على حاله نحن لا ننظر ولا
نحلم نحن نريد حقا للشعب السوري نحن نفصل
ما بين الملاحقه الجنائيه نفصل ما بين
التحقيق نفصل ما بين القانون ونفصل ما بين
السياسه اذا كان هناك مبادره سياسيه فل
تتقدم جامعه الدول العربيه وتبادر
بالسياسه وتوقف حمام الدم ولكن ليس على
حساب ان يراق مزيد من الدماء اذا انتظرنا
هذه اللجنه بمعدل 70 قتيل يوميا سيكون
هناك 2100 قتيل في المده المخصصه له هذه
اللجنه وهي شهر واحد به بهذا نختم الحلقه
شكرا جزيلا لؤي ديب رئيس الشبكه الدوليه
لح
للحقوق والتنميه وشكرا جزيلا للسفير محمود
شكري المحلل السياسي وسفير مصر السابق لدى
سوريا وشكرا لوليد البني عضو الامانه
العامه ومدير مكتب العلاقات الخارجيه في
المجلس الوطني السوري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرا